as many of you know Israel is a very
important issue to me and Donald Trump
has chosen a complete and utter
unmitigated disaster to be the United
States ambassador to Israel I cannot
explain to you how horrible this choice
is although I'm going to try and as you
may know my views on Israel or sometimes
caricatured as right-wing or hard right
by some people in our audience
particularly on YouTube the reality is
that any honest assessment of my views
can't possibly come out with that
verdict I'm hugely against Benjamin
Netanyahu and those types of right-wing
religious coalition Israeli government
I'm completely against settlements in
Israel I'm against unilaterally moving
the capital of Israel from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem and this is a big issue of
contention so within Israel uh the sort
of conventional wisdom is Jerusalem is
the capital however Jerusalem is
currently disputed in the same way that
Gaza and the West Bank are so
internationally Tel Aviv is considered
the capital of Israel and even though
Israel might like to move uh officially
move the capital to Jerusalem with
regard to international law so for
example the United States Embassy is in
Tel Aviv not in Jerusalem if Israel were
to say yeah move it to Jerusalem because
that's the capital that would be hugely
destructive and damaging to peace talks
so that gets us to David Friedman Donald
Trump is selected David Friedman to be
the United States ambassador to a UH to
Israel first and foremost Friedman is an
expert in being a predatory capitalist a
bankruptcy lawyer who is aligned with
the farthest far right in Israel really
true deplorable but what's most
important is what are Friedman's views
on Israel where though they're they're
ridiculously dangerous beliefs number
one Friedman said he looks forward to
doing the job from the US Embassy in
Israel's capital of Jerusalem the
embassy has been in Tel Aviv the status
of Jerusalem as the capital of Israel is
Indus
and it would be hugely damaging to any
possibility of peace to make the
unilateral decision to move the capital
to Jerusalem before that has been
negotiated and if it ever is negotiated
I can't explain to you how damaging this
is if you want real peace talks
unilaterally moving the embassy to
Jerusalem is a very very bad idea now
here's where it gets even crazier
Friedman is actively Pro settlements now
let me give you a sense of the this the
spectrum here the scope if you don't
follow this issue closely
I'll give you sort of a cheat sheet a
very very left position on settlements
would be go in and destroy every Israeli
settlement okay that would be like a
very very left position a moderate left
position would be stop all settlement
construction today and agree to remove
the settlements that can be a
practically remove reasonably removed as
part of a peace agreement and then you
do meaningful land swaps for the
settlement that can't be practically
removed this is my view
yes sir arafat was conceptually okay
with the idea of meaningful land swaps
for the settlements that can't be
removed that's a sort of moderate left
position the center right to right wing
position is the settlement that exists
now are fine but Israel could agree may
be to stop building more Freedman said
that he doesn't believe it would be
illegal for Israel to annex the West
Bank and he supports building new
settlements there and all over Israel
the position of even more settlements is
so extreme and so outrageous that it
will make what what is already I mean
let's be those be frank here it's an
uphill battle with regard to serious
peace talks right now in the
israeli-palestinian conflict an
ambassador who says more settlements is
arguably one of the worst three or four
characteristics that an ambassador to
Israel could have J Street is opposed to
this nomination now J Street most
reasonable Jews who are liberal in the
United States realize that this is a
terrible terrible choice and to give you
a sense of how out there free
is Friedmann compared J Street to Capo's
Capo's the Jews who cooperated with
Nazis during the Holocaust basically
saying J Street is a group that is is
super super liberal I'll remind you that
J Street is way way way too conservative
for many anti Israeli liberals in the
United States and Friedman comes in and
says J Street and its followers are sort
of like Nazi collaborators this is a bad
bad path forward it's difficult for me
to imagine a worst pic then David
Friedman if goal if if if the goal here
is serious peace talks and of course in
the background of this is that Donald
Trump's thinks that his son-in-law Jared
Kushner is gonna show up and negotiate
peace this is a fantasy world a Trump is
living in a total fantasy world with
regard to how he thinks the
israeli-palestinian conflict is going to
improve under his leadership the idea
that Friedman is an ambassador and
Kushner as a peace negotiator are going
to do anything to help is absolute and
utter nonsense really really disturbing
to anybody who wants serious peace uh of
productivity or a movement in the
direction of peace in the
israeli-palestinian conflict